this morning the world's largest music
streaming site is going public on the
New York Stock Exchange analysts say the
company could be valued at more than
twenty billion dollars that's with the
be Spotify will launch with the direct
listing of shares not an IPO so this
removes the traditional role of
investment banks
it means existing Spotify shareholders
can sell stocks directly to the public
while the company says the goal is to
make investment in the business more
transparent so only on CBS this morning
Spotify co-founder and CEO Daniel act
joins us at the table to discuss
congratulations is in order to you mr.
act this morning thank you but clearly
you didn't get the memo because normally
people do this they're down on the stock
floor they're ready to bail they're
taking picture right everybody's
congratulating him you're here because
you wanted to do it differently why well
I I really think that when you look at
our company and when I started thinking
about this we started this company when
I was 23 years old what were you
thinking at the time well I mean for me
someone growing up in suburbs
working-class suburb in Stockholm I
couldn't afford all the music so back in
98 99 I was really thinking about how I
could get all that music and do it in a
legal way while at the same time
compensating the artists and that's
where the idea of Spotify came up and so
we're now like a decade into that
journey and I really just feel like
we're in the second inning so so while
this is obviously a big day and I'm very
proud of my employees I really just feel
like we're in the early days not
celebrating the end days as so many
other companies like you are doing what
have you learned about the way people
listen to music one thing obviously is
they're willing to stream music instead
of having it in their heads but what
else are you learning about the way
people have behaved in this new world
well I think the most interesting things
is when you have all the world's music
in your pocket you start listening to a
lot more music than you ever did before
by a lot more artists than you ever did
before
and in very different moments of time so
take New Yorkers as an example it turns
out that the number one
New Yorkers listen to music is between
10:00 p.m. and 11:00 p.m. even a week
days whoa it's really the city that
never sleeps right yeah 10:00 p.m. I
made a playlist it took me an hour you
really can focus on what people are
listening to and when they're listening
to it yeah and we can get you on all
platforms that's the thing I was at the
dentist yesterday they said what do you
want to hear we have everything on
Spotify Bruce Springsteen's greatest
hits I mean so instantly they queue it
up yeah exactly and that's the
interesting thing and that's whether
you're in your car or whether you're in
your home or whether you're at the gym
and and that's the other thing that's
really different about how consumers are
doing this they're they're really going
for gym playlists they're going for the
barbeque playlists that we have in
really setting different moods and
moments later but Daniel you stepped on
some toes because the artists let's take
Tara for instance they thought they
weren't fairly compensated right so you
know you bruised a lot of people's
feelings and now you and Taylor are back
together there's a song she's got a song
love story right it says baby just say
yes is that what you did it was slightly
more complicated but look I mean I for
me first off like I should have done a
much better job communicating this so I
take full ownership for doing that go to
her yeah I went to Nashville many many
times to talk to her team spend more
time directly explaining the model why
screaming mattered and and the great
news is I think she saw how streaming
was growing I think she saw that fans
were asking for it so eventually when
the new album came up she came to
Stockholm and spent some time with our
team they're figuring out a way that
made sense for her you've got some
enviable rivals including Apple I see
you wearing an Apple watch so you
haven't banned the product selves but
the Wall Street Journal is reporting
that they're going to take over is the
number one streaming site by this summer
are you skir you what are you doing
you're scared well we are about twice
the size of them so I think we've still
got some room and
I'm very happy with the growth that
we're seeing in our business I can't
speak for them but I feel pretty calm
but I do a little concern though well I
the funny thing is like when you have
something like music that billions of
people around the world care about
you're never gonna be alone right yeah
like this is too big and it matters too
for too many people
so actually what we found is when we've
got competition it actually grows the
market because more people are now
talking about streaming it's easy to
forget that just three years ago even in
the u.s. streaming wasn't really a
saying it was still downloading songs so
this helps educate the market and that's
equally true across the world be honest
are you gonna follow the stock price at
all today well I'll look at it when it
opens but but my focus is really on the
long term yeah you're always looking at
the big picture you're not like the
other kids in the class sorry they call
you a slayer and a savior what do you
say well III don't know I I don't really
focus on that I focus on getting people
to listen to more music than ever before
I know surprised I'm here at all thanks
so much thank you so much for having me
congratulations and you can always
discover the music we play on our
broadcast by following the show Spotify
playlist check CBS this morning dot-com
for daily playlists
posts